bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat à suivre ce matin une
audition menée par la commission des
finances suite à l' enquête de la cour
des comptes sur l'entretien du réseau
ferroviaire national
cette audition a été initiée par la
sénatrice ump de la gironde
marie hélène des esgaulx cette audition
a pour objectif d'entendre les
différents magistrats qui ont mené cette
enquête pour la cour des comptes
il s'agit aussi de recueillir les
observations de la sncf de réseau ferré
de france ou encore du ministère de
l'écologie tout de suite donc retour à
cette audition qui a eu lieu mercredi
dernier salle clemenceau mes chers
collègues pardonnez moi de ne pas faire
le tour de la table mais je ne voudrais
pas accroître le retard avec lequel nous
ont tellement cette audition et je suis
confus de ce retard mais qui est
provoqué par une réunion préparatoire à
une autre audition dans le cadre du même
article 58 de la lolf monsieur le
président déchu macaire réunion qui
avait lieu qui se poursuit d'ailleurs
avec votre collègue monsieur le phare la
semaine prochaine nous avons donc une
autre audition de cette nature sur le
centre national de la cinématographie
également audition ouverte à la presse
et qui peut être aura encore plus de
succès n'est ce pas auprès de
l'extérieur mais je crois que déjà sur
le réseau ferré national
et il y a un très réel intérêt et qui
dépasse de beaucoup les limites de notre
assemblée par conséquent dans le plaisir
d'accueillir le président de cette de la
7e chambre
monsieur christian les bancaires bien
sûr
c'est la cour qui est qui voilà oui
absolument et donc monsieur monsieur ont
connu il faut pas faire de d'image la
cour elle ne n'obéit pas aux
classifications d'une assemblée
parlementaire et hilti the joke alors
monsieur andré lemaire le rapporteur
monsieur françois cazala le contre
rapporteur ce qu'ils expriment tradition
des procédures collégiale sein de la
cour et les les organismes concernés
réseau ferré de france monsieur alain
quinet donc le directeur général délégué
et pour la sncf
monsieur pierre izard directeur général
de sncf infra
ça veut dire infrastructures je suppose
et pour le ministère de l'écologie
ministère chargé des transports monsieur
daniel bursaux le directeur général de
l'infrastructure jeu bursaux cessa de
l'infrastructure des transports et de la
mer
table ronde ouverte et avec en
particulier nos collègues membres de la
commission du développement durable et
d'aménagement du territoire et la
benjamine de nos commissions que
président
mon collègue le sénateur raymond vall et
nous allons donc procéder à cette
audition filmée et retransmise en direct
sur le site internet du sénat
c'est je crois d'abord à l'initiative de
la rapporteure spéciale ou de madame le
rapporteur spécial puisque chacune et
maîtresse de son appellation donc c'est
madame le rapporteur spécial dans
l'espèce et des crédits relatifs au
transport et aux infrastructures madame
marie hélène des esgaulx donc c'est à
son initiative que nous deux
la tenue de cette audition
et comme
comme à l'ordinaire la cour va si elle
le veut bien nous présenter
succinctement les conclusions de son
rapport
puis la discussion s'engagera mai afin
que 2 de mieux lancer le débat et de
permettre à la cour mais je pense que
ceci a fait l'objet d'une utilisation de
se concentrer sur l'essentiel
et bien c'est marie-hélène des esgaulx
rapporteur spécial qui va à présent
s'exprimer et poser les bases de cette
problématique que nous allons aborder ce
matin merci monsieur présidente très
rapidement mes chers collègues
mesdames et messieurs effectivement la
commission des finances a demandé à mon
initiative à la cour des comptes de
procéder à une enquête sur l'entretien
du réseau ferré national
allez fais depuis trois ans que je suis
rapporteur spécial j'avais eu l'occasion
de m'interroger sur l'organisation de la
gestion de notre infrastructure
ferroviaire
d'un côté rff propriétaire et
gestionnaire et de l'autre sncf infra
gestionnaire délégué qui fait quoi à
quel coût pour quelle efficacité bien à
ces questions je dois dire que les
principaux acteurs apportent des
réponses souvent contradictoires il me
semblait donc important que la cour des
comptes puissent nous permettre
d'objectiver les termes du débat et la
seconde question concerne évidemment
l'équation financière de la maintenance
du réseau
comment pouvons-nous garantir un
entretien qui assure la qualité la
sécurité du réseau ferré compte tenu des
contraintes financières que nous
connaissons tous
voilà à très grande près les raisons qui
m'ont conduit à solliciter cette enquête
et je remercie la commission d'avoir
bien voulu accéder à marquette
je pense que cette enquête ces résultats
tombent au bon moment tombe vraiment
comme il faut je voudrais surtout
remercier les membres de la cour des
comptes qui ont travaillé sur ce rapport
c'est un effet
un rapport de mon point de vue d'une
très grande qualité qui nous apporte un
éclairage très approfondies sur ces
questions et qui font reçu ressurgir je
dirais tous les problèmes que l'on peut
se poser
on est parti d'un petit sujet et
l'entretien est en fait ce problème on
le voit bien dans votre rapport fait
resurgir absolument tout ce qui est
important à l'heure actuelle dans sur
cette question je vais donc laisser la
parole à la cour des comptes
plus particulièrement au président de la
7e chambre rapporteur et au contrat
apporteur pour qu'ils nous présentent
leurs travaux
vion merci merci chers collègues nous
allons donc entendre la cour pour une
première intervention el rey
interviendra différentes reprises dans
le débat
cette première intervention vous le
savez monsieur le président il serait
souhaitable que vous ne dépasserez point
un quart d'heure voilà c'est entendu
monsieur premier vous voudrez bien me
pardonner
étymologiquement le mot audit à quelque
chose avec l'oreille je suis
difficilement audible aujourd'hui
j'espère que vous ne m'en tiendrai pas
rigueur comme comme madame des esgaulx
l'indiqué une demande a été adressée à
la cour des comptes parlait du 21
novembre 2011 pour que la cour mène une
enquête sur l'entretien du réseau
ferroviaire national alors tout de suite
une précision du langage le terme
entretien doit elle est entendue pendant
dans ce travail comme maintenant
l'intense désignant à la fois
l'entretien au sens dépenses de
fonctionnement et le renouvellement au
sens dépenses d'investissement donc
c'est une acception large du mot
entretien qui a été retenue avec
l'accord de madame le rapporteur spécial
ce qui était demandé c'était 2-1 avec la
cour analyse le fonctionnement du
système très spécifique à la france qui
a été créée par la réforme de 1997
et qui fait reposer la gestion du réseau
ferroviaire sur deux acteurs rff qui est
depuis la réforme gestionnaire
d'infrastructure est propriétaire du
réseau et la sncf ghsr l'infrastructure
délégués et cette mécanique complexe
constitue un des chapitres du rapport de
la cour bien entendu ce que la cour
ainsi de faire c'est d'analyser les
résultats de la politique menée dans ce
domaine de l'entretien elle est partie
bien sûr du fameux rapport rivier de
2005 rapport de l'école polytechnique de
lausanne puisque la référence en matière
ferroviaire c'est souvent cette école
polytechnique de lausanne
donc le rapport rivier de 2005 qui qui
avait jeté un froid sur l'état du réseau
et la cour a également assuré le suivi
des recommandations qu'elle avait
formulées dans un rapport de 2008 sur le
réseau ferroviaire de poing une réforme
inachevée une stratégie incertaine alors
les points principaux que je souhaite
présenter et qui ne sont pas mon opinion
bien entendu mais celle de la cour des
comptes
ces points sont les suivants
premièrement la maintenance est un
véritable défi à main tendue des réseaux
est un défi pour quoi
d'abord parce que le réseau a des
caractéristiques qui rendent cette
maintenance difficile et lourde
d'abord il ya la taille si on raisonne
en voit plutôt qu'en ligne puisque une
ligne ses succès souvent de voix 48 km à
entretenir et on peut même y ajouter et
15000 kilomètres de voies de service
donc c
c'est déjà rien que ce chiffre indique
l'ampleur de la tâche autre
caractéristique la diversité 1800 km de
lignes à grande vitesse
treize mille 800 km de lignes classiques
du réseau dits structurants et 13600
donc pratiquement autant de 13 mille six
cents kilomètres de lignes du réseau
secondaire et il faut avoir en tête que
près de 70% de ce réseau secondaire est
parcouru par moins de 20 trains par jour
et on à 6400 km de voies qui sont
parcouru pas moins de dix trains d'un
jour s'est pas beaucoup titre autre
caractéristique du réseau son
hétérogénéité je passe vite bien sûr
mais un point qu'il faut évoquer c'est
l'hétérogénéité par référence aux
anciennes compagnies concessionnaires
il y a encore des courants et de
détention de courant électrique
différentes selon l'endroit où l'on se
trouve
je ne parle pas des tunnels non les
gabarits sont variables
donc cette hétérogénéité ne facilite pas
l'entretien et si j'évoque ces points
presque historique c'est parce que une
partie une partie de l'équipement est
date d'avant la création la sncf c'est
d'ailleurs un signe de qualité de ce qui
avait été construit à l'époque
enfin l' architecture de réseau c'est un
réseau relativement peu mallet alors peu
mallet ça signifie que quand on ferme
une voix on ne sait pas par vous faire
passer le train en langage très simple
c'est ça donc on évite de faire mais une
fois on l'a fait pendant 2h 3h 1h40 et
et on l'a remis en service
l'entretien est beaucoup plus difficile
que quand on peut carrément fermé ligne
et faire passer le train ailleurs le
défi apparaît aussi en raison du retard
qu'ils étaient accumulés dans la
maintenance retard qui est lié
essentiellement à la très forte baisse
des investissements de renouvellement du
réseau
depuis le début des années 80 autrement
dit depuis que l'on s'est lancé dans la
construction des lignes à grande vitesse
la corrélation est forte et personnel
contestent
on l'a fait des lignes à grande vitesse
on a sacrifié l'entretien du réseau le
renouvellement du réseau existant et
cela signifie que pendant longtemps il y
avait une politique implicite d'abandon
d'une partie du réseau
mais je dis bien implicite puisque il
s'agissait simplement de peu à peu de
créer une sorte d'accoutumance à l'idée
qu'une ligne mine devait en raison de
son état être utilisé avec des vitesses
moindre donc on ralentit celi train pour
éviter des accidents
enfin d'autres aspects du défi c'est le
coup nous sommes sur un sujet à 2
milliards d'euros en ce moment où chaque
année et le plan de rattrapage de
renouvellement qui a été élaboré pour la
période 2008 2015 représente 13
milliards d'euros d'investissements
donc ceci c'est le premier point la
maintenance est un véritable défi
technique financier
deuxième point la laborieuse
articulation entre rff et sncf
bien sûr ceci ne vise pas les personnes
ici présentes elles le savent bien
mais depuis la réforme de 1997
la relation entre les deux
établissements publics a été d'une très
grande complexité
le dispositif conventionnel qui a été
mis en place pour la maintenance que la
sncf partie infra assuré pour le compte
de rff
ce dispositif est d'une très grande
complexité et aux rushs dire une partie
de l'énergie des deux établissements
publics a consisté à essayer de régler
les différends qui apparaissait au fur
et à mesure donc un système complexe
avec néanmoins un point positif qu'il ne
faut pas négliger c'est l'émulation que
qu'à créer rff à l'égard de la sncf avec
une sorte d'abandon du monopole qu'elle
avait la sncf la sncf s'est trouvée mise
en concurrence dans certains cas de
manière très limitée mais là la menace
existe et s'est mise en a été mise en
concurrence
donc il s'est créé une tension sur la
sncf qui pouvait être favorable à des
gains de productivité
il n'empêche que les gains de
productivité n'ont pas permis une
réduction des coûts des coûts de
l'entretien
puisque on constate un renchérissement
un renchérissement de des dépenses
pourquoi renchérissement quelques
raisons rapidement d'abord la
multiplication de chantier créer une
tension du côté des entreprises capables
de mener à bien ces chantiers le de plus
en plus il a fallu faire des travaux la
nuit des travaux l'année coûte plus cher
que les travaux le joue donc on a on
constate une augmentation des coûts
troisième point le réseau ferroviaire
continue de vieillir
malgré l'effort incontestable et
important qui a été menée depuis le
constat fait par le rapport rivier
malgré le doublement des investissements
annuels de renouvellement
l'âge moyen des voix continuent
d'augmenter et ce qui est préoccupant
c'est que le réseau qui vieillit le plus
c'est le réseau structurant et le réseau
qui a le plus bénéficié de l'effort de
renouvellement c'est le réseau
secondaire parce que c'est plus facile
d'interrompre la circulation parce qu'on
y travaille plutôt de jour que de nuit
parce que parce que la pression la
pression locale a été plus forte
toujours est il que dans l'effort de
renouvellement menée ces dernières
et le réseau secondaire a davantage
bénéficier des des du renouveau que le
réseau structurant ce qui est une
préoccupation et quatrième point une
reine
une rénovation du réseau de plus en plus
financé par l'endettement
rff parce que nécessairement été amenés
à recourir de masse au micro de façon
croissante à l'endettement
et alors je ne développerai pas le sujet
de la dette ferroviaire qui est un sujet
en soi mais il n'y a pas de miracle si
il y avait un effet plus qu'il y avait
un effort de renouvellement il fallait
bien le financer les péages ne ne
suffisait pas assurée ce financement on
l'agouti donc à des choix
elle a l'idée qu'il faut faire des choix
difficiles mais que ses joies son
inéluctable comment infectées au mieux
une ressource de plus en plus rares la
location de cette ressource devra
d'abord porté sur les investissements il
faudra choisir plus que ça n'a été fait
ou peut-être mieux que ça n'a été fait
entre préserver le réseau existant et
développer de nouvelles lignes
c'est un sujet qui était largement
débattue l'année dernière aux assises du
ferroviaire
il faudra se poser la question
inévitablement de la taille et de la
consistance du réseau un effort
financier important a été fait j'ai les
10 et 7 fr ne permet pas de rajeunir le
réseau il faudrait donc soit un effort
encore plus important sur le plan
financier soit une réduction de la
taille du réseau
donc moins de kilomètres à renouveler et
entretenir la cour ne serait conclure le
rapport en disant que d'un trait de
plume
on peut rayer à son tour de lignes
ferroviaires
tel n'est pas l'esprit du rappeur teigne
pas d'ailleurs son contenu mais il nous
semble possible d'imaginer une action
concertée avec les collectivités
concernées sur cette taille du réseau en
se souvenant que qui dit transport local
voire même ter ne dit ne dit pas
forcément train il y a des des dessertes
qui sont assurés par d autres cas et
ceci évidemment conduire et à réduire
l'ampleur du problème
voilà monsieur le président j'en ai
terminé ce stade
si beaucoup monsieur le président vous
avez bien posé les principes au terme de
cette problématique je vais donc me
tourner vers les deux organismes qui
entretiennent des relations
contractuelles complexe et lourd de nous
dit on et me tourner aussi vers la
tutelle monsieur le directeur général
serait souhaitable que vous puissiez
réagir sur trois thèmes la cour a relevé
et que le système de relations
conventionnelles entre rff et sncf infra
est à bout de souffle
je cite elle a relevé que la dérive des
coûts de la maintenance est manifeste
elle a relevé que l'on a plutôt tendance
à se concentrer sur des petites lignes
que sur des grandes
alors quelles sont vos éléments de
réponse à ce sujet j'ai le souvenir
pardonnez moi cette facétie qu'il y a
quelques années on se gaussait de la
situation de nos amis anglais qui avait
été caractérisé d'ailleurs par des
accidents et on disait nous notre
système est meilleur alors est-ce qu'il
l'ait réellement et second thème et qui
résultent du premier à la fin de l'année
la ministre d'alors ministre en charge
de l'écologie des transports avait
annoncé lors de la clôture des assises
du ferroviaire une unification de la
gestion de l'infrastructure
c'est à dire une fusion sncf infra rff
alors l'ancien gouvernement
la paf est le nouveau pas encore ou pas
davantage il n'a pas communiqué sur ce
sujet donc il serait heureux que nous
puissions connaître vos orientations au
moins vos opinions et en troisième lieu
s'agissant de l'équation financière de
la maintenance du réseau ferré et la
cour estime me semble-t-il sous son
contrôle que sans évolution structurelle
sur la taille du réseau la maintenance
va inexorablement conduire à
l'augmentation sensible au moins un
milliard par an de la dette de rff
alors je sais bien que l'on fait des
efforts méritoires pour ne pas présenter
cette dette avec celle de l'état
néanmoins il est bien clair que rff est
un établissement public de l'état que
sans l'état rff n'existerait pas que
cette dette même si elle n'est pas
formellement peut-être susceptible
d'être qualifié de maastricht yens
c'est un engagement financier de l'état
même si c'est pas juridiquement
économiquement c'est incontestable
donc la progression de la dette de rff
est un réel problème pour les finances
publiques
cela entre dans l'ensemble des problèmes
que nous avons à traiter et partagez
vous avec la cour le sentiment que
l'équation financière actuelle n'est pas
tenable
voilà messieurs je vous livre ses
questions pour que vous puissiez vous
aussi de manière synthétique répondre
assez assez assez observations à cette
analyse de la cour à la suite de quoi le
président valent le rapporteur général
qu ils sont des finances la rapporteure
spéciale et nos collègues qui ont
demandé la parole vont pouvoir nourrir
la discussion de leurs questions
dans l'ordre qui vous semblera le banc
messieurs les anglais tirez les premiers
monsieur le président mais voilà voilà
qui est bien
voilà qui nous satisfait pour assumer
envers les met d'accord
eh bien monsieur le président merci
merci de me donner la parole je voudrais
réagir effectivement assez brièvement à
quelques-uns des quelques uns des points
qui ont été évoquées par le président hô
pitaux repris par vous même sur la
difficulté des relations entre les deux
entreprises
mes voisins s'exprimeront je pense
qu'effectivement l'organisation telle
qu'elle est aux un certain nombre de
difficultés qui ont néanmoins été
aplanies ces derniers temps mais que à
terme ce qui ressortit effectivement des
assises du ferroviaire à savoir qu'il
fallait s'orienter vers un gestionnaire
d'infrastructure unifiée fait très
largement consensus parmi tous les
acteurs du système ferroviaire
ça serait une source de simplification
et de mise en tension du système pour
peu que l'on puisse conclure qu'elle est
a conclu avec ce j'ai eu un contrat de
performance dans le qualifier 6 des
objectifs à la fois en termes
qualitatifs et quantitatifs et financier
sur la gestion du réseau
donc sur ce point on pourra plus
détaillé les raisons qui ont créé des
difficultés mais je crois que c'est pas
forcément l'objet sur l'objectif il est
clair cette question qui est celle que
vous aviez déposé à la fin de votre
intervention
elle est clairement au centre des
réflexions que mène actuellement le
gouvernement le sujet étant comment
positionné cgi dans une architecture
nouvelle est que ce soit compatible
avec les la réglementation européenne
sur la problématique de la dérive des
coûts là aussi rff pour en dire un peu
plus mais il est évident que maintenant
que l'on s'attaque aux lignes les plus
circuler du réseau pour faire de la
régénération
il ya des vraies problématiques de
maintenir la circulation
et comme l'a dit le président de china
caire nous généralisons de plus en plus
les travaux les travaux de nuit ce qui
évidemment entraîne des surcoûts sont
négligés d'ailleurs un certain nombre
d'aspects à la fois de sécurité des
aspects sociaux que la sncf infra
connaît connaît bien donc c'est une
explication importante de la dérive des
coûts l'autre explication la dérive des
coûts s'est malheureusement que nous
avons connus ne dérive des coûts des
matières premières en particulier de
l'acier qui effectivement entre d'art je
mens dans la production et dans les
graphiques et enfin dans la production
des travaux sur le sur le fait que les
petites lignes étaient
traités en priorité j'ai vu que ça vous
avez surpris monsieur le président c'est
effectivement surprenant mais il ya deux
raisons très très objectif qui ont
justifié ça la première raison c'est que
effectivement c'était de loin les lignes
sur la qualité le plus simple de faire
les travaux et que lorsqu'il a été
question de faire le plan de relance qui
a été qui avait été décidé en 2000 en
2008-2009 les premiers travaux qui
pouvait être fait est de toute évidence
cela puisqu'il nécessite l e -
d'organisations complexes à mettre en
place
c'est évidemment pas du tout la même
chose de faite attendre sur une île où
il ya dix trains que sur l'île où il ya
plusieurs dizaines de trains qui
circulent par jour
ceci dit ce n'est pour l'instant et
c'est bien comme ça que c'est compris
c'est une programmation en avance par
rapport aux travaux qui sont maintenant
actuellement lancés sur les grandes
lignes sur lesquelles nous nous
attaquons donc in fine l équilibre qui
était prévu de régénération entre le
réseau je dirais principal et le réseau
secondaire sera là sera maintenu donc il
ya vraiment cet effet du plan de relance
et puis il ya une deuxième raison qu'il
faut qu'il faut aussi bien bien donner
c'est que les régions effectivement ont
vu un grand intérêt effectivement avoir
des cofinancements des travaux de
régénération sur le réseau secondaire et
que ça a effectivement à mener des plans
de financement qui ont également
accélérer un peu le système les deux
raisons extrêmement objectifs qui ont
qui ont conduit à ça ce résultat qui
peut paraître paradoxal mais encore une
fois qui clairement devraient être
rattrapés dans les toutes prochaines
années sur la fermeture
de nombreuses lignes du réseau
secondaire je ne m'aventurerai pas
beaucoup sur ce terrain vous en doutez
monsieur le président je dirais qu'une
politique nationale qui consisterait à
dire il ya x milliers de kilomètres du
réseau qu'il faut fermer une à mon avis
aucune chance d'aboutir et n'est pas
souhaitable je pense par contre que de
traiter au cas par cas avec les régions
les lignes qui paraissent effectivement
les plus il est plus fragile les moins
fréquentées et d'examiner au cas par cas
s'il ya des possibilités de substitution
routière qu'un accord entre des
entreprises publiques et les régions et
l'état est une piste qui doit pouvoir
permettre effectivement de régler un
certain nombre d' un certain nombre de
cas et de diminuer un tout petit peu la
taille du réseau
mais encore une fois l'idée d'imaginer
une politique générale qui conduisent à
ça je ne pense pas que ça soit en tout
cas pour l'instant
une piste qu'on puisse vraiment visage
et je suis d'ailleurs expliqué avec la
cour lorsqu'il court bien voulu
m'auditionner sur ce sujet vous voilà je
crois sur la première thématique
si si vous souhaitez le plus simple
c'est peut-être qu'on parle des
thématiques les unes après les autres
est ce que à ce stade les représenter un
groupe sncf et rff des considérations à
faire valoir
si vous arrêtez monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs c'est la teuf
peut-être deux ou trois remarques
d'introduction la première c'est que la
cour des comptes nous auscultent sous
divers angles depuis plusieurs années et
je pense qu'elle commence à bien
connaître le réseau ferré et donc je
crois que les conclusions qui vous sont
soumises paraissent à la fois documenté
documenté et raisonnable même si elles
sont parfois un peu douloureuse attend
entendre pour les entreprises concernées
la deuxième chose c'est que
je crois que si la création de rff il ya
15 ans a une vertu c'est au moins de
faire émerger le réseau ferré existant
comme objet industriel à part entière
avec je crois et je crois cette audition
le montre une meilleure une meilleure
connaissance de l'état physique du
réseau de ses coûts de ses recettes et
donc je crois que il y a là un gain de
transparence qui est utile au débat
public
alors ce que je voudrais peut-être dire
de manière très synthétique sur le fond
c'est que suite notamment à l'audit
rivier qui a été cité et qui a été très
structurant pour nous un effort très
considérable de renouvellement du réseau
de montée en puissance de ce
renouvellement était engagé depuis
depuis maintenant trois ans ce qu'il
faut bien comprendre c'est qu'on est
aujourd'hui dans cette phase je dirais
de montée en puissance du renouvellement
qui évidemment soulève de manière au
moins transitoire deux questions qui
sont la question des travaux et les
cautions l'équation financière
nous sommes aujourd'hui dans un travail
de rénovation qui a doublé depuis
quelques années et donc chaque année
nous rénovons by km de voies c'était 500
km il ya quelques années et donc on voit
bien que cette montée en puissance des
travaux créé à son de perturbations sur
possible sur la circulation notamment
sur la circulation en zone dense qui
sont celles qui ont crû de plus vite au
cours des années récentes
et donc on est face à un sujet à premier
sujet je dirais industriels qui tenait
moins de directeur général mais sans
doute un lapsus vous avez dit chaque
année nous rénovons combien de
kilomètres 1000 km lui mille kilomètres
km contre 500 km au lieu de 500 voilà
donc on a effectivement un premier sujet
qui est un sujet industriel qui et
comment je dirais continuer ses travaux
en minimisant l'impact sur la
circulation notamment dans les zones
denses le deuxième sujet c'est que ce
travail de rénovation qui monte en
puissance
il cote puisque on parle au delà des 2
milliards dépensés sur l'entretien
courant du réseau d'un effort
d'investissement de 1
hier 7 environ et il est clair que nous
sommes dans une phase où l' enveloppe
dédiée à la rénovation augmentent sans
que à ce stade là elle et d'effets
visibles sur les coûts d'entretien du
réseau
il est bien clair que on s'attend à
terme à ce que l'effort de rénovation et
le rajeunissement du réseau permet des
économies sur l'entretien
aujourd'hui cet effort de rénovation est
trop récent pour qu'ils aient des effets
visibles et tangibles sur l'entretien
donc voilà tout ça pour dire qu'on est
aujourd'hui dans cette phase je dirais
de transition qui est compliqué à gérer
à la fois sur le plan du ciel champions
financiers et de ce que je voudrais
peut-être juste dire simplement pour
terminer cette introduction c'est que
dans notre esprit cet effort de
rénovation qui est engagée il doit être
poursuivi
il doit être poursuivie sans doute pour
encore plusieurs années et il doit
gagner en efficacité et donc je pourrais
si vous souhaitez revenir pour vous dire
de quelle manière on peut envisager de
poursuivre cet effort de rénovation en
cherchant la foyers en efficacité sur le
plan de circulation et sur le plan des
sur le plan des coûts
comme monsieur le directeur général de
cette réponse tout à fait direct merci
aussi au directeur général du ministère
donc à au groupe sncf de s'exprimer
merci monsieur le président je voudrais
peut-être revenir sur quelques éléments
concernant le réseau et les coûts d'une
part et de le système d'autre part tout
d'abord le réseau lui même ça a été dit
dans la première présentation reste
encore un réseau vieillissant c'est à
dire que nous ne sommes pas encore
parvenus au niveau de renouvellement des
composants est la politique à une
politique de renouvellement d'un niveau
suffisant pour endiguer le
vieillissement du réseau
alors bien sûr que le volume qui a été
évoquée à l'instant ralenti cet effet
vieillissement mais nous ne l'avons pas
encore totalement endigué et de plus le
fait que nous n'ayons renouvelé
globalement que 500 km de voies par an
pendant près d'une trentaine d'années 25
ans au lieu de beaulieu d'un millier qui
est de l'ordre de grandeur que nous
jugeons nécessaire ensemble avec réseau
ferré de france montre qu'il ya je
dirais un déficit d'entretien élevé de
maintenance élevés qui s'est accumulée
et ceci conduit un état du réseau en
patchwork si je peux me permettre ce mot
c'est à dire que devant de la réduction
des moyens financiers qui étaient à
notre disposition nous avons alors
choisi de remplacer tantôt leur ait en
poule le ballast entre les traverses en
faisant de petites zones plutôt que de
grandes zones autrement dit nous sommes
d'aujourd'hui aux prises avec un réseau
très hétérogènes en termes de
d'état général sauf sur les lignes à
grande vitesse
nous avons choisi de ne jamais renoncer
à des renouvellements massif autrement
dit quand nous décidons de remplacer des
rails entre paris et lyon nous le
faisons sur la totalité de la longueur
quand on transforme le ballast là aussi
on le fait de manière très massives je
le disais à l'instant donc il faut
arriver au bon niveau de renouvellement
des composants les sillons le résume
souvent ou km devoir renouveler les
autres composants sont aussi au coeur de
nos préoccupations que ce soit les
caténaires des systèmes de signalisation
des spasmes en train de les postes
d'aiguillage le besoin de renouvellement
concerne tous les sous systèmes et pas
exclusivement la voix humaine alors le
la relation contractuelle entre rff et
nous même assez bref ça a été mentionné
par alain quinet crée une tension une
une exigence en terme de recherche
d'efficacité de la part de cette
infrastructure et je dois dire qu'au
cours de ces six dernières années ça
nous allons veiller à transformer nos
méthodes à transformer nos organisations
à faire mieux apparaître nos trois
grands métiers la circulation
ferroviaire la maintenance des travaux
sur le réseau et l'ingénierie de
réalisation de la maintenance et des
projets nouveaux et que toute cette
transformation a conduit à alléger les
structures à réduire des coûts
interne et est également nous a poussés
à nous comparer à nos collègues d'autres
pays d'europe
nous avons demandé aux chemins de fer
suisses de venir faire un état des lieux
d'apprécier quelles étaient nos méthodes
ça s'est passé en 2008 2009 de nous
recommander quels progrès nous pouvions
faire nous avons comparé nos méthodes
également avec celles d'autres pays
d'europe tout autour de nous en
regardant comment nos standards
techniques pouvaient se comparer nos
méthodes d'intervention pouvait être
évoluer tout ceci d'ailleurs constitué
des programmes de productivité que nous
faisons vivre chaque année et que
d'ailleurs nous cherchons à renouveler
sans cesse puisque nous entamons
actuellement un nouveau cycle de
définition de nouvelles opérations de
d'efficacité de productivité
alors je crois que ça a été dit par
dernier de berceaux tout à l'heure le
regroupement des compétences
d'infrastructures tout nous y sommes
tous très attachés est convaincu que
c'est là une piste nécessaire
le modèle d'aujourd'hui est morcelé il
conduit à ce que les intérêts des uns et
des autres ne soient pas rigoureusement
aligner chacun de ces logiques résonne à
partir de sa responsabilité de son
domaine d'intervention est donc que les
procédures ont quelque peu pris le pas
sur la recherche de performance est sans
doute est il là de nouvelles choses à
faire même si depuis 2010 nous avons
beaucoup travaillé ensemble à rapprocher
nos équipes et à leur demande et sur des
projets en commun de nous faire leurs
meilleures propositions pour faire
évoluer l'état du réseau et donc notre
conviction c'est bien que gestionnaire
d'infrastructure intégralement
responsable aura une politique
d'efficacité en termes de qualité des
sillons qu'il délivre aux transporteurs
une politique industrielle et technique
qu'il faudra reconstruire évoquée puis
bien sûr tout ceci en portant la
responsabilité sociale et regroupant 50
mille personnes puisque la somme des
compétences d'infrastructures
d'aujourd'hui de rff circulation
ferroviaire sncf infra représente un peu
plus de 50000 personnes
voilà les premiers éléments que je
souhaitais
merci beaucoup monsieur le directeur
général alors je vais à présent passer
la parole au président val s'il le veut
bien plaisir d'accueillir les membres de
sa commission nombreux ici ce matin
merci monsieur le président est sûre je
pense qu'il est normal que les membres
de cette nouvelle commission sont
nombreux puisque je crois que tous les
thèmes cette nouvelle commission sont
concernés par cette audition et je
voudrais d'ailleurs féliciter et
remercier ma collègue madame des égouts
d'avoir évidemment provoqué à la fois ce
rapport dont je remercie la cour et les
premières réactions même si ses
premières actions n'amène aucune
surprise en ce qui nous concerne puisque
nous avions auditionné le président de
rff en 2010 nous avions découvert à ce
moment là le déficit ton méprisant
marini a parlé nous avions été révolté
par le fait que le président avait
reconnu lui-même qu'il n'avait pas de
partenaire financier d'ailleurs pour
continuer ce qui était assez révoltant à
la au moment où nous avions apporté une
attention particulière à ses partenaires
financiers et enfin l'examen du snit
nous avait évidemment conforté dans
l'idée que certes l'urgence concernant
les problèmes de foie ferrer de
transport voyageurs étaient évidentes
mais qui avaient aussi notion
d'aménagement de territoire sur lequel
laquelle notre commission sera très
vigilante et à ce titre je suis l'élu
d'une région qui
en midi pyrénées a vu donc cette région
se substituer à rff en investissant plus
de 600 millions d'euros pour que cesse
entre 700 millions d'euros
mon collègue corrige puisqu'il ya eu des
négociations au dernier moment pour
transférer une partie de cet argent sur
la route près de 700 millions d'euros
pour que les trains ne s'arrêtent pas à
ce propos je considère d'ailleurs que là
il ya un crédit ouvert que forcément
nous serons obligés de faire des choix
monsieur bur ceux-là et le rapport le
précise mais il serait totalement
injuste que dans les régions on some
substituer en avance sur le réseau ter
il y eut ensuite dans les choix
une non prise en compte d'une partie de
cette avance financière qui a été fait
est qu'ils n'en n'ont diable surtout
quand elles se cumule avec la
participation éventuelle potentiel futur
des tgv géo bordeaux toulouse
donc nous serons très vigilants et
encore une fois je remercie mes
collègues de la commission des finances
d'avoir ouvert ce débat qui est capital
pour notre territoire
merci merci monsieur le président la
suite de vos de vos propos je suis tenté
de passer tout de suite la parole à
françois patriat car la problématique
régionale est évidemment au coeur de
notre débat tout ce qui a été dit en
particulier sur les lignes secondaires
est lié
et aux compétences des régions à leur
mode d'intervention à leur budget est
beaucoup plus largement d'ailleurs
s'agissant du schéma et de l'évolution
des infrastructures les régions sont des
partenaires essentiels dans ce jeu
institutionnel
donc chers collègues vous souhaitiez
vous exprimer sur le sujet vous avez la
parole
merci monsieur le président ici le
directeur mais si les présidents
oui j'ai souhaité réagir en paix parce
que au-delà de ce constat accablant voir
répétitif sur l'état du réseau et sur le
manque de réponses efficaces qui nous
sont proposés je voudrais rappeler que
dans ce domaine domaine des transports
les trains compétences région
l'effort réalisé par les régions seul
bien-être signale alain thomas mon
collègue pour midi-pyrénées j'avais
retenu chiffre de 800 millions que me
donnait melvin 700 l'effort propre des
régions est aujourd'hui monsieur le
président du triple ce que les
transferts d'état lui avait confié alors
que les régions aujourd'hui ont
multiplié par 3,3 la somme qui leur
avait été transféré pour s'occuper des
trucs pour agir sur les trains alors
nous sommes aujourd'hui co financeurs
vous l'avez dit dans les plans de
relance poitiers le plan de relance
les régions ont été aussitôt associés
nous y sommes dans les contrats de plan
en dehors de nos compétences dans
l'infrastructure
nous y sommes dans les ter nous y sommes
dans les lgv et nous y sommes dans les
comités de ligne puisque chaque semaine
lorsque je participe à un colis des
lignes j'ai des mécontentements notoire
de dire des voyageurs vous vous rendez
compte monsieur le président le nombre
de retards dans les trains consécutifs
et quand il faut et qu'il faut expliquer
aux voyageurs de joany ou de sens huit
mille personnes prennent le train chaque
jour un sens pour venir travailler à
paris que pendant deux ans encore à
cause des travaux sur paris lyon
ils auront tous les
des retards de train des trains
immobilisés en rase campagne sans
explication pendant une demi-heure
imaginez que c sur les régions que
revient la difficulté alors on a payé
les lgv là pour des sommes collègues de
franche-comté ratages et ses sondes
avons payé et de se croire dans les
conventions avec la sncf sur les
directeurs et présidents nos conventions
augmente de pratiquement 5 à 8% par an
est la réponse que nous fait la sncf
c'est de dire mais nous sommes
confrontés à une hausse des péages
hausse des péages importante qui se
répercute dans vos conventions et des
conventions je vous donne l'exemple de
la convention pour la région bourgogne
elle est passée entre 2007 et 2012 de
105 millions à 155 millions d'euros
convention annuelle sommes à
compressible dans les économies qu'on me
demande de faire aujourd'hui
alors j'ai bien entendu monsieur disant
que vous tombiez de remplacer quelques
lignes peu de voyageurs je comprends par
des bus là encore les vous avez répondu
qu'on pouvait pas le faire plus je sais
pas si on va pas le faire plus mais tu y
vas y en aura bien un moment au devant
l'inadéquation financière pour parler un
peu avec l'ès 1 le monde est moyen il
faudra bien trancher
vous dites aujourd'hui 1000 km de
rénovation par an c'est un rythme qui
est soutenu je le conçois j'ajoute que
les régions ont fait passer le matériel
de transport en huit ans d'une moyenne
d'âge de 35 ans à 15 ans d'âge vont
participer par le même alain tests
entrepris je vous connaissez les
entreprises ici en france
ce tome d'autres canadiens à côté donc
on pourra pas demander plus aux
collectivités
je sais pas si une piste atrassi
aujourd'hui il faudra bien qu'on fasse
le choix entre les lignes totalement
déficitaire les lignes sur laquelle on
fait passer des trains à grande vitesse
et des ter
et puis les nouvelles lgv qu'on doit
construire est-ce qu'on a les moyens de
faire les trois montants aujourd'hui
tous les problèmes il ya des lignes qui
sont engagés aujourd'hui exemple sur la
ligne
lgv rhin-rhône est ce qu'il faut
aujourd'hui construire la branche sud
la branche ouest ou bien est-ce qu'il ne
faut pas pour faire une économie mettre
en situation dijon lyon je prends cet
exemple parce que je le connais bien
pour qu'il puisse y avoir dessus et les
lgv qui descend donc strasbourg et les
ter tous les jours une fois pour toutes
on fait des travaux et on fait
l'économie d'une ligne lgv
supplémentaires
moi j'aimerais qu'au delà des deux
pistes qui ont été ou des trous poursuit
la rénovation oui mais comment et avec
quoi là vous posez les questions vous
donner les engagements les personnes
aujourd'hui le dal les solutions
merci beaucoup au président françois
patriat donc la cour et les
représentants des entreprises et la
tutelle répondront et j'espère manière
précise à cette intervention qui est
très riche et très documenté qui par
parenthèse montre que le cumul des
mandats peut comporter aussi certains
avantages
pardonnez-moi pardonnez moi de le
rappeler est un petit clin d'oeil et et
je vais donc demander à le rapporteur
spécial de revenir dans le sujet avec
quelques questions brèves peut-être
rapporteur je n'ai pas lui demander s'il
souhaite s'exprimer ensuite donc nos
invités répondront puis nous allons
prendre l'ensemble des questions et j'ai
déjà des dd j'ai déjà des demandes de
michel teston robert navarro marie
france beaufils jean paul emorine mais
sans préjudice d'autres collègues voilà
yves krattinger claude au soir également
s'exprimer
donc madame la rapporteure spéciale
merci monsieur le président je vais
rester dans les trois points que vous
avez soulevés notamment sur le premier
kill une efficacité et le coot de
l'organisation actuelle je suis tenté de
vous poser une première question
alain quinet pierre izard et et daniel
bursaux selon vous en matière de gestion
de l'infrastructure
je voudrais vous demander tout
simplement qui est le chef qu'est ce
qu'ils décident alors c'est vrai que
j'en conviens c'est c'est presque un peu
impertinent poser cette question mais
mais c'est tellement révélateur
pardonnez-moi de la situation actuelle
donc je voudrais vraiment que cette
question vous osiez y répondre et puis
quoi aussi vous nous expliquer quand
même sur l'inefficacité est toujours et
le coot actuelle comment on a pu arriver
à aujourd'hui à ce point bureau
bureaucratique procédurier on est arrivé
devant quelque chose qui est qui et qui
est absolument inextricable
à la lecture du rapport je voudrais
aussi dire qu'il me semble que la
tutelle apparaît quand même étrangement
absente et je vous pose la question
pourquoi l'état n'a pas pris ses
responsabilités pour porter remède aux
défauts structure
quand même de l'organisation française
comment se fait-il que quatorze ans
après rff ne soit toujours pas en mesure
d'assurer seules la maîtrise d'ouvragé
pourquoi on a autant de données qui lui
manque que sur sur la connaissance des
du réseau ça c'est quand même quelque
chose qui m'interpelle
est-ce que rff doit favoriser
l'ouverture à la concurrence pour la
maîtrise d'oeuvre
je pose la question est ce qu'il existe
des entreprises capables de rivaliser
avec sncf infra c'est quand même ça le
sujet et est ce que le mode de
rémunération au forfait de sncf infra
doit évoluer
ou est-ce qu'au contraire il faudrait
pas préférer un paiement après contrôle
préalable des travaux par rff ce qui me
semblerait quand même assez logique
voilà pour l'essentiel des questions sur
le premier point sur le deuxième point
président marine y en a très bien parlé
mais la question c'est effectivement de
savoir si l'état envisage toujours de
réaliser l'unification de la gestion de
l'infrastructure et si oui selon quel
calendrier selon quelles modalités
parce que franchement semble sans même
parler des problèmes techniques
je me pose la question quand même s'il
est réaliste que l'on puissent fusionner
dans un seul ensemble deux entreprises
qui sont quand même culturellement
habitués à se disputer
on fait ce qu'il faut pas craindre une
résurgence alain termes de tension entre
les anciens sncf infra et les anciens
rff en tout cas comment faut-il éviter
tout cela
la cour estime en tout cas dans sa
recommandation numéro 2 qu'il faut
assurer l'émulation du futur
gestionnaire unique par un contrat de
performance exigeants en matière
d'objectifs et de résultats de maîtrise
des coûts et de gains de productivité
dans la mise en oeuvre serait vérifiée
par des audits extérieur et à soucht est
assorti de mécanismes d'intéressement
alors le sujet c'est comment la tutelle
entend-elle mettre un oeuvre cette
préconisation en fait sur le dernier
point qui est l'équation financière de
la maintenance de
offert et c'est vrai que très
sincèrement je vois savoir s'il ya des
études aujourd'hui sur le
dimensionnement du réseau actuel et quel
avenir
on peut réserver notamment au réseau
secondaire c'est quand même ça le vrai
vrai vrai sujet ça a été très très
exactement dit avant moi et moi je
voudrais faire observer que l'abandon de
cette certaines parties du réseau
dégagera des ressources pour l'entretien
et le renouvellement des lignes les plus
fréquentées mais il ne réglera pas les
problèmes d'arbitrage de rff entre le
besoin d'assurer ses recettes
commerciales et celui de réaliser une
maintenance au quotidien alors la
question c'est les objectifs du contrat
de performance toujours qualifié de
contradictoire par par la cour des
comptes sont ils réalistes
voilà j'ai essayé d'être le plus court
possible monsieur le président il ce
sujet est passionnant
merci chers collègues donc le nom
invités vont s'efforcer de répondre dans
quelques instants sur le gestionnaire
unique et la fusion beaucoup d'entre
nous sont dubitatifs car bon la mise en
tension par le contrat entre les deux
organismes a sans doute des vertus
peut-être les avons-nous exagéré lorsque
ce dispositif a été créé en 96-97 mais
pour autant faut-il aujourd'hui vraiment
faire le contraire et créer quelque
chose d'encore plus considérable et
difficile à gérer
c c c c est une réelle question pour
beaucoup d'entre nous sur le rapporteur
général
oui monsieur le président juste
deux choses pour compléter ce qu'a dit
très bien madame des ego on a conscience
que l'équation financière et est
terriblement difficile aujourd'hui
donc ma première question est simple
c'est de savoir s'ils n'y a à l'heure
actuelle des anticipations rationnelles
fiable qui sont conduites pour voir de
quelle façon
outre ce qui est annoncé sur la
limitation de l'usagé des lignes
secondaires où les ajustements des
arbres des investissements à venir
on nous annonce qu'il y aurait des
changements importants des réduction de
périmètre sur les ambitions qu'on avait
par le passé
est ce qu'il y à des anticipations
financière rationnelle qui nous
permettrait d'être éclairé sur la façon
dont on anticipe les choses parce que un
milliard et demi de dettes de plus par
an on sent très bien que dans le
contexte actuel ça tient plus sous très
peu de temps et donc j'ai une corde a
déjà un peu réfléchi à la question et la
deuxième interrogation que je voulais
faire valoir en complément de ce qu'a
dit le rapporteur spécial porte sur
votre ce que vous avez dit sur les
comparaisons au sein de l'europe
est ce que à travers ces comparaisons
que l'on peut faire aujourd'hui où les
concertations que vous avez avec
d'autres compagnies en europe vous en
tirer quelques enseignements
est ce que par exemple la comparaison le
modèle allemand vous apporte quelques
pistes s'agissant de la consolidation de
l'ensemble des des capacités d'action au
sein d'une structure unique s concerne
l'europe vous trouver matière à
vous donnez un peu d'optimisme sur la
façon au fond d'organiser les choses
pour l'avenir comme ceux leur apportons
gerald su si vous permettez je jouais
peut-être prendre encore deux
interventions retrait aussi concise que
possible et ensuite la cour et nos
interlocuteurs vont s'efforcer de
répondre donc je me tourne vers michel
teston pour la commission du
développement durable sénateurs bercy le
chemin président je voudrais faire part
brièvement de quelques remarques sur les
principales recommandations du rapport
de la cour mais évoqué aussi un aspect
essentiel qui n'est pas abordé ce qui
m'a étonné dans ce rapport c'est la
question de la résorption de la dette
historique de rff
parce qu'un effet je vois pas comment on
peut recommander une réorganisation du
système ferroviaire
si on ne traite pas en parallèle la
question de la dette de rff
alors quelques mots sur les cinq
recommandations premières
recommandations l'unification de la
gestion de l'infrastructure ferroviaire
président marini a dit que certains
étaient sceptiques
d'autres ne le sont pas je fais partie
de ceux qui depuis de nombreuses années
plaide ici au sénat pour qu'on sorte du
dispositif qui a été mis en place en
1997 qui a créé beaucoup de difficultés
avec cette séparation non contre le
gestionnaire d'infrastructures et
l'opérateur historique et avec en plus
une gestion déléguée par rff et sncf
infra donc de ce côté là en ce qui me
concerne je trouve que cette
recommandation
emon deuxième et troisième
c'est donc l'effort d'efficacité et de
gain de productivité comme pierre izard
l'a rappelé rff et alain quinet l'a dit
aussi rff et la sncf ont consenti des
efforts importants de productivité au
cours des dernières années il faut
certainement aller encore plus loin
est-ce qu'il faut un contrat de
performance c'est avoir probablement que
c'est effectivement quelque chose qu'il
faut envisager mais il faut langue à
l'envi
j'ai dans un cadre pluriannuel de
manière à ce qu'on puisse effectivement
trouver les bonnes solutions pour
rénover principalement le réseau à des
coupes qui soit plus équilibrée
quatrième recommandations privilégier
l'action de rénovation alors ça c'est
effectivement quelque chose d'important
il faut à l'avenir comme on la demandait
depuis de nombreuses années privilégier
l'action de renouvellement de rénovation
par rapport à l'action se dirait
quotidienne de maintenance qui coûte
extrêmement cher et par contre je
voudrais faire une remarque sur la
recommandation de la cour qui a dit
qu'il faut privilégier le réseau
structurant par rapport aux réseaux à
faible trafic
cela paraît être une évidence toutefois
comme l'a dit françois patriat les
régions consenti des efforts importants
sur le matériel mais aussi pour certains
d'entre elles pour la rénovation du
réseau et certaines petites lignes
présente un intérêt pour la desserte
régionale et donc dire a priori qu'il
faut absolument privilégier le réseau
structurant par rapport aux réseaux à
faible trafic c'est ne pas tenir compte
finalement des souhaits des régions ça
doit être fait en lien avec les régions
voilà donc pour ces quatre
recommandations la 5e et hiérarchiser
les lignes du réseau secondaire par
d'utilité décroissante
bon ça paraît logique là aussi par
contre moi je voudrais vous dire qui on
voit ressurgir tous les 15 ans cette
idée qu'il faudrait fermer de nombreuses
lignes de nombreuses petites lignes
alors je ne suis pas favorable
personnellement à cette évolution parmi
les raison très simple c'est que je ne
pense pas qu'on construira une nation
équilibré si on ne prend pas en compte
la ménagement du territoire et raymond
vall notre président a eu raison de
rappeler notre attachement au sein de la
commission développement durable des
infrastructures de l'équipement et de
l'aménagement du territoire sur cet
aspect qui nous paraît essentiel
un dernier mot sur le manque de ce
rapport alors c'était peut-être pas
l'objet effectivement de la demande
émanant du sénat mais on sait que y
manque chaque année les assises du
ferroviaire
il ya quelques mois l'ont confirmé un
milliard d'euros chaque année pour
le bon fonctionnement du système
ferroviaire or chaque année je pense que
le directeur général adjoint de rff
confirmera mes propos et à faible doit
trouver sur le marché financier 1,4
milliard d'euros pour pouvoir financer
sa dette et donc quand on rapproche de
somme on se rend compte que si on
trouvait une solution pour pouvoir
permettre rff de rembourser rff ou à la
nouvelle structure je sais pas comment
fonctionnera l'avenir de rembourser
cette dette historique on aurait fait un
effort considérable pour trouver les
moyens pour accélérer la rénovation du
réseau et peut-être par ailleurs dans
ces conditions pour pouvoir poursuivre
peu à peu le déroulement aussi du réseau
à grande vitesse voilà les quelques
remarques que je souhaitais faire mais
ce sont vraiment pour l'instant des
remarques très générale parce qu'il me
semble qu'il faudra qu'on avance
davantage notamment sur la question de
la réorganisation du système ferroviaire
national
est ce ton pour terminer cette salve
cette série d'interventions tout très
substantiel je me tourne sur marie
france beaufils représente un groupe qui
ne s'est pas encore exprimée et qui est
en plus maire d'une ville de tradition
ferroviaire merci merci monsieur le
président oui quelques quelques
interrogations par rapport à aux
présentations qui ont été faites tout à
l'heure je crois que la question qui
nous est posée c'est en effet il ya
quelques années on a eu les travaux de
l'école de lausanne qui ont permis de
mesurer l'ampleur du chantier qui était
à engager j'aurais trouvé intéressant
que vous puissiez nous dire quelle est
la proportion de de ce que l'école de
lausanne demander qui a été
véritablement mis en oeuvre aujourd'hui
par pour avoir une bonne mesure de de ce
qu'il nous reste à faire je pense que
c'est important même si comme vous le
disiez tout à l'heure
le réseau a continué à se dégrader par
rapport à bien sûr ce que disait cette
étude
à cette période deuxième deuxième
question qui me semblent importantes
dans la réflexion que vous avez abordé
vous dites que la hiérarchie dans le
soir enfin en tout cas c'est comme ça
que je l' ai compris fait que ça vous
semble presque anormal qu'on est
peut-être un peu trop privilégier le
réseau disons secondaires par rapport
aux réseaux plus plus intense en termes
de trafic et je pense aussi que ce
serait intéressant que vous ne disiez si
c'est parce que les régions apporter
leur contribution
parce que c'est peut-être aussi quand
même une des motivations qui a fait que
ce choix a été réalisé parce que sinon
on ne comprendrait pas pourquoi en effet
ce choix a été décidé donc moi
j'aimerais bien qu'on se mette bien
d'accord sur sur cet aspect parce que ça
semble être important il ya un point que
vous n'avez pas abordé du tout et et moi
j'aimerais savoir si vous avez fait
l'investigation c'est qu'actuellement
ligne lgv sont essentiellement financée
par des partenariats public privé avec
l'idée que peut-être par rapport à ce
qui s'était fait précédemment ou en
effet quand on a fait les grandes lignes
lgv on a abandonné une part du
financement de la maintenance du réseau
peut-être qu'en prenant des ppp on
réduire et l'exigence de financement
direct par rff ou par la sncf
est-ce que ça n'est pas reculer pour
mieux sauter parce que on sait que si on
fait faire par les ppp on va avoir à
rembourser et à prendre en charge quand
même des choses lourdes et que le coût
de l'infrastructure va se reporter sur
des péages qui risque d'être plus élevé
et qui vont donc se retourner en
direction particulièrement de la sncf ou
des régions et qui risque de se
retrouver avec des capacités moindres
des régions de participer à la
régénérescence du réseau de ter donc moi
j'aimerais bien savoir si vous avez un
petit peu fait d'investigations là
dessus enfin vous savez que je ne suis
pas partisan tu bien sûr du ppp mais bon
ça ne change rien j'aime bien qu'on avec
stieg aussi sur un choix fait un moment
et que l'on puisse dire si oui ou non
servait de l'intérêt ou pas je pense que
c'est bien d'avoir aussi l'auto critique
dans ce domaine moi je voudrais revenir
aussi après avec notre collègue michel
teston sur mon attachement à
l'aménagement du territoire
en ce qui concerne le réseau ferré moi
je ne partage pas du tout l'idée que
d'engager un programme de substitution
des lignes les moins fréquentées par des
liaisons par autocar alors heureusement
vous ajoutez ensuite appuyé cette riche
et rare cheese à sion sur des bilans
financiers sociaux et écologiques du
réseau secondaire heureusement qu'il ya
ce bilan ne proposait verrière parce que
réduire la capacité d'utiliser le réseau
ferroviaire est de mettre sur car aura
des incidences ou aurais je préfère le
dire comme ça aurait des incidences qui
pourrait être lourde en termes
écologiques
je crois quand même qu'il faut qu'on le
prenne en compte et puis en termes de
réalité des infrastructures routières et
là ce sont d'autres collectivités qui
prennent en charge mais il faut bien
voir l'ensemble de la réalité économique
du sujet et puis tout à l'heure vous
parliez des maillages insuffisant
réduire des voix aujourd'hui moins
utilisé est ce que ce n'est pas réduire
le maillage et rendre encore plus
difficile la capacité de reporter sur
une partie du réseau quand vous vous
enfermez d'autres donc moi je je je
trouve que dans ce domaine là la réponse
elle n'est pas aussi simple me
semble-t-il dans ce domaine dernier
point que je voulais aborder tout à
l'heure vous avez dit que dans dans les
coûts élevés qui qui sont ressenties
aujourd'hui dans la rénovation
vous avez bien sûr le fait qu'on
travaille de nuit mais vous avez dit
aussi que la multiplication des
chantiers avait rendu plus difficile la
capacité des entreprises existantes à
faire face est ce que vous pourriez être
un petit peu plus précis dans ce domaine
je pense que ce serait pour nous
important parce que s'il faut développer
l'activité industrielle de ces
entreprises ferroviaires ça mérite quand
même qu'on puisse peut-être regarder
d'un peu plus près ce qu'il en est quand
je ne reviens pas sur l'entreprise
intégrée vous savez combien moi je suis
intéressé à ce sujet mais pas seulement
sur la fera
merci à marie france beaufils voilà donc
la cour le ministère sncf rff en
s'efforcer de répondre et tendance à
penser que on oppose un peu trop que les
grandes infrastructures et les entre
guillemets petite ligne parce qu'il ya
aussi une problématique commune
j'observe est un élu du grand bassin
parisien que la régularité des trains
pour nos usagers quotidiens dépend pour
une bonne part et le respect des
horaires des travaux des grands travaux
sur les grandes infrastructures des
grandes lignes donc ce que disait
françois patriat sur le caractère dual
de certains itinéraires il faut bien le
le prendre en compte c'est l'un des
éléments de la problématique
alors monsieur le président de la 7e
chambre et quels sont les éléments de
réponse que vous inspire toute cette
série d'interventions
monsieur le président je ne pourrais pas
répondre à toutes les questions qui
interposés parce que la cour n'a pas
travaillé sur tous les sujets je pense à
la question des ppp pour l'instant les
ppp c'est plutôt en devenir
donc nous n'avons pas traité ce sujet et
je ne pourrai rien en dire en revanche
il ya des sujets que nous avons déjà
évoqué dans des travaux antérieurs par
exemple le bilan écologique de la
substitution du remplacement d'un d'un
train par un autocar c'est pas si simple
parce que le train en général et sur une
voie qui n'est pas électrifié de sorte
que si elles étaient électrifiés la voix
bien sûr la réponse serait simple
il vaut mieux la voie ferrée que
l'autocar mais sinon c'est un peu diesel
contre diesel 1 c alors en ce qui
concerne la dette la dette de rff le le
sénateur testons a tout à fait raison de
dire que nous n'avons pas traité le
sujet mais c'est à dessein parce que la
commande initiale c'était l'entretien
bon en accord avec madame des égaux nous
avons bien compris que l'entretien
devait être compris au sens large
mais j'espère que vous admettrez que de
proche en proche
ça serait tout le système ferroviaire
français qu'il aurait fallu traiter
là ça dépasse un peu j'allais dire nos
compétences humaines
en tout cas est donc très objectivement
nous l'avons pas fait je les dis dans
mon propos et il est sûr que c'était un
sujet très important mais bon là dessus
je ne peux pas répondre le cnca patriat
a dit il il faut choisir il ya des choix
à faire
nous ne disons rien d'autre en ce qui
concerne le double double usage des voix
alors là je préfère ne pas répondre ne
pas m'aventurer dans un domaine où je
risquerais d'être pris en défaut
le double visage par un train grande
vitesse lancer réellement dans le huit
est et un ter là je crois que la réponse
est simple ça ne se fait pas le double
usage d'une ligne par un tgv roulant à
une vitesse normale et un ter
je présume que c'est possible je ne
pourrais pas répondre surtout pas
répondre sur l'itinéraire qui était
mentionné dans la vraiment site
c'est aux entreprises de répondre voilà
les quelques remarques que m'inspirent
les questions qui ont été posées mais je
souscris à beaucoup beaucoup de
remarques qui ont été faites et y
compris d'ailleurs celles qui relèvent
l'incontestable effort qui a été réalisé
celle qui dit on est passé de 500 km à
mille kilomètres par an ça n'est pas
rien bon évidemment 1000 km a porté à 48
mille kilomètres mais c'est déjà mieux
le reste c'est de l'arithmétique toute
simple je laisse ça à tout un chacun eu
un retour qui a été évoquée cac avait
demandé l'école de lausanne et que
demande-t-elle l'école de lausanne
travail à nouveau sur l'état du réseau
ferroviaire
nous n'avons pas eu connaissance des
résultats de l'audit qui est en cours
actuellement
je sais que les voisins suisses se sont
aperçus qu'il y avait certains éléments
qu'ils avaient sous-estimé quoi
notamment les aiguillages parce qu'il
n'est pas ligne proprement dit ce qui
renchérit encore les travaux à faire
mais je le répète ce document n'était
pas terminée comme nous avons fait notre
contrôle
il est peut-être terminée maintenant
donc je m'arrête là dessus puisque je
n'ai pas vu ce document si beaucoup
monsieur le président alors état et
entreprises
si vous voulez bien sûr le directeur
général monsieur le président merci je
vais tenter d'apporter quelques éléments
de réponse la question frontale qui a
posé madame des ego sur qui décide je
pense quand même quelle réponse qui est
assez simple les tout ce qui est travaux
neufs
que ce soit les travaux ligne nouvelle
vous les travaux prévus dans les
contrats de plan état région
c'est clairement l'état puisqu'elles
signature qui engage les tailles des
décisions qui sont prises par l'état sur
cette thématique là sur les travaux de
maintenance dont on parle aujourd'hui
principalement l'état a signé un contrat
effectivement avec rff contrat de
performance avec rff prépare la
signature d'un nouveau contrat pour la
pour l'avenir et c'est dans ce contrat
que l'on définit les grandes
orientations qui sont fixés à rff pour
la maintenance du réseau
alors évidemment ces contrats ne prévoit
pas ligne par ligne ce qui sera fait
mais l'état clairement affiche par ce
biais ses priorités et des orientations
qui souhaitent donner à la maintenance
sur le sur le sujet du sur le sujet du
j'ai eu je ne parle pas là de
l'entreprise intégrée globale je parle
vraiment dû j'ai eu les acides ont
effectivement déboucher sur une
conclusion qui était relativement
unanimes sur cette thématique là sur le
fait qu'il fallait unifier le
gestion d'infrastructures le problème du
positionnement étant une autre question
qui reste est effectivement pour
l'instant pas tout à fait tranché sur
lequel que je le disais tout à l'heure
le gouvernement est en train de
travailler très activement il ya un
certain nombre de raisons j'ai pas tout
les évoquer manana il y en a une
principal lorsqu'on a construit le
service annuel 2012 pour une circulation
on s'est aperçus qu effectivement les
gens qui préparait les travaux au sein
de sncf infra n'était pas toujours
complètement en relation avec les gens
qui traçait les sillons et dans
l'élaboration de ce schéma
il ya eu des vraies des vraies surprises
parce que effectivement des sillons qui
était tracé sans tenir compte totalement
des travaux qui étaient prévus pouvait
ne pas tout à fait réalisable donc il va
servir ce qu'il y avait un véritable
besoin effectivement de rapprocher et
sur le plan je dirais fonctionnel et sur
le plan ii des systèmes d'information
l'ensemble des gens qui travaillaient
sur les deux problématiques tout c'est
une des raisons je crois principal qui
plaide pour cette médication du
gestionnaire le sujet encore une fois de
la relation de l'entreprise verrière est
sans doute un sujet assez différent mais
sur gestionnaire d'infrastructure pense
que ça ne souffre pas ça ne souffre pas
de débat un autre exemple typique et les
difficultés aussi que nous avons qui est
que constater un certain nombre de
tunnels effectivement qui adore le
travaux de remise en état ont été
repoussée d'année en année parce que ça
crée effectivement des difficultés de
circulation
il ya un moment où il faut effectivement
qu'un gestionnaire d'infrastructure qui
est la responsabilité de ces choses là
et qui prennent la décision de le faire
dans les meilleures conditions possibles
bien entendu mais c'est un clairement
une fonction de gestionnaire
d'infrastructure sur les sujets puis je
reviendrai
deux minutes après sur les problèmes
financiers sur le sujet des fermetures
des petites lignes dans mes propos je me
suis peut être mal exprimé mais
j'ai pas dit qu'il fallait pas avant
visage et un peu plus de fermeture j'ai
dit que ça devait être négociée vraiment
au cas par cas et être regarder
effectivement de très près en fonction
d'études d'impact qui soient faites et
des possibilités sérieuses ou pas de
substitution routière
ce que j'ai dit et ça j'en suis
profondément convaincu c'est que décrété
dans qu'on se fixe un objectif de x
milliers de kilomètres de fermeture de
ligne ça me paraît tout à fait tout à
fait impraticable à la fois vis-à-vis
des usagers vis-à-vis des collectivités
qui ont participé à l'ensemble des
travaux donc il ya vraiment une
réflexion à mon avis cas par cas affaire
epad pas de politique globale qui soit
envisageable
et pour répondre aussi à madame beaufils
moi je confirme je vais me semble elle
avoir un ticket dans les premières
interventions que oui le fait que les
travaux soient quitte lille est pris il
avance par rapport effectivement aux
autres aux autres travaux il y avait
certes effectivement les premiers des
problématiques d'organisation parce que
c'est plus compliqué de faire des
travaux sur les lignes très circuler
c'est ce qui évoquait monsieur le
président mais il y avait clairement
effectivement l'effet du plan de relance
qui avait décidé par le gouvernement
actuel est également l'apport par les
régions évidemment de leur contribution
financière enfin le cadre de midi
pyrénées a été citée ce n'est pas le
seul il ya eu aussi un gros effort qui a
été fait en particulier dans la région
où verne puisqu'il ya eu aussi un
contrat pour un plan et en bourgogne sur
sur l'équation financière sans rentrer
dans le détail je pense que quelques
quelques points peuvent être évoqués
d'abord je crois qu'il faut regarder de
près puisqu'il ya eu des commentaires
qui ont été faits sur le coût des
travaux
je pense que c'est intéressant mais
alain qui n'a sûrement des éléments de
faire des comparaisons avec ce qui se
passe dans nos pays dans les autres pays
européens
et je ne suis pas sûr que la maintenance
tel quel et opérés actuellement sur le
plan financier soit des coûts nettement
plus élevé que dans que dans nos pays
voisins mais mes deux voisins pourront
en parler plus longuement que ce soit la
quina ou pierre izard qui s'est beaucoup
intéressé à ce sujet
ou ou pays en asie dont les cours
intègrent bien sûr les frais de
structure des entreprises concernées sur
et istres et je pense utiles à nos
commissions d'avoir un tableau de
comparaison par rapport à des fonctions
analogues dans les pays européens avec
lesquels vous êtes en relation bon
souvent des élus locaux par exemple
quand on leur demande de co financer des
travaux sur des gars comparant les deux
vis du maître d'ouvragé sncf à des devis
généralement quelconques pour des
travaux généralement quelconques
constate qu'il ya un écart significatif
est liée aux structures de l'entreprise
au déversement des différents étages de
frais est-ce qu'il en va de même dans ce
domaine de la maintenance ferroviaire
on peut comprendre que c'est quand même
très spécifiques et qui vient des
prescriptions très lourds très précise à
prendre en compte
non c'est bien pour ça je tenais à
mettre ce sujet sur la table comme une
fois je crois qu'il ya quelques éléments
qui peuvent être donnés je suis convié
toutes les entreprises et l'état pour
vous apporter des informations
complémentaires sur ce sujet ensuite les
sources des sources d'économies c'est ce
qui a été évoqué c'est bien évidemment
la mise sous tension du système avec des
obligations qui seront prévues dans un
prochain contrat de performance pour les
deux entreprises et notamment une
surveillance très précise des gains de
productivité d'ailleurs la sncf infra c
est aujourd'hui engagée sur les gains de
productivité de 0 8% je dirais à
structurer galles et considère ce qui
rejoint d'ailleurs les analyses qui ont
été faites considère que si demain il ya
un gestionnaire de la structure unifiée
ce gain de productivité pour être porté
à 25 % donc il ya des vrais sujets a
effectivement en termes de structure sur
cette thématique sur laquelle on doit
pouvoir
m faire baisser les coûts et d'étendre
un peu le point financier
le troisième proche et évidemment ce qui
a été évoqué la problématique de
l'affectation des contributions
publiques entre l'affectation sur la
régénération du réseau et sur les
travaux neufs
c'est un véritable sujet sur lequel le
gouvernement a décidé de se pencher
puisqu'il on sait qu'il y aura une
réévaluation des projets du snit c'est
évidemment dans l'objectif de 2 de
regarder plus vrai l'arbitrage entre
travaux neufs et travaux de maintenance
et de régénération essentiellement et
puis le sujet qui est toujours fait
couler beaucoup d'encre mais qui à mon
avis n'est pas clos qui celui-là
polymathique des péages puisqu'ils
évidemment les péages permettre à rff de
financer ses travaux
mais qui ne peuvent pas être fixés non
plus à des niveaux qui soient
insupportables tant par les régions que
par la sncf entreprise servir pour ces
tgv voient quelques lignes de réponse
monsieur le président sur les
différentes questions merci beaucoup
monsieur le directeur général donc
monsieur qui n'est présent
oui merci monsieur le président si vous
me permettez je voudrais faire 4.4 point
synthétique
le premier point qui décide je crois
qu'il faut on gagnerait à distinguer
clairement les choix politiques et les
choix industriels
il ya des choix politiques affaires qui
sont pas de notre ressort sur la
consistance du réseau ou sur les types
de trafic que l'on veut voir sur ce
réseau la france a des ambitions fortes
à la fois en termes d'aménagement du
territoire et en termes de mix télé
trafic puisque nous nous avons un réseau
qui est au service à la fois de la
grande vitesse des trafics régionaux et
vue du fret
pour ce qui des choix industriels
mosquées qui sont gérés de 2 du ressort
du maître d'ouvragé puis et puis du
maintenant ce que je voudrais dire très
clairement c'est que notre rôle face une
équation financière qui est souvent
présenté comme un possible
c'est justement de rendre cette équation
financière - impossible et je pense que
il y a
au sein de nos entreprises un potentiel
de performance industrielle important
que nous cherchons à mobiliser qui je
pense dans la durée peut aider aussi à
résoudre cette équation financière je
voudrais vous en donner très simplement
3,3 exemple premier exemple l'effort de
rénovation actuellement effectivement le
pfl qui a fait l'audit dit rivier il ya
cinq ans est en train de revisiter de
faire un point d'étape à notre demande
sur
je dirais l'avancement de ces travaux
leur efficacité ce que nous dit le pfl
en quelques mots c'est premièrement que
cet effort de rénovation il doit
évidemment être poursuivi que
deuxièmement effectivement il doit être
concentrée sur le réseau structurant
classiers parce que en termes
chronologique jusqu'à présent l'effort a
été fait sur le réseau à grande vitesse
simplement parce qu'il est plus jeune et
aussi sur lignes régionales parce que
comme cela a été dit notamment par
monsieur patriat
les régions ont cofinancé cet effort là
maintenant comme l'a dit le président
comme on est sur un réseau qui est très
interconnectés tout le monde a à gagner
à ce que les grands les grands axes
classique classique structurants du
réseau fassent l'objet de la même
attention le pfl ou d'une deuxième chose
nous dit que l'effort et doit être
massifiés c'est vrai que peut-être que
par le passé faute d'argent
la rénovation porté sur des petites
portions dax ce 10 km par 6 10 km par là
là où ça ne paraissait le plus urgent
est évidemment pour que la rénovation
porte du fruit et sous efficace il faut
qu'elle soit massifier est donc
maintenant nous avons des travaux de
rénovation qui porte sur
des centaines de kilomètres entière sur
des axes je pense notamment l'axé
atlantique et donc je crois qu'on a cet
effort qui est maintenant beaucoup plus
industrialisés la troisième chose c'est
que la rénovation et doit être globale
c'est à dire que ont fait pas une année
une année la voix et puis l'année
d'après on revient à couper la
circulation pour faire la caténaire ce
que nous dit le pfl c'est que la
rénovation elle doit être globale
axe par axe le deuxième point que je
voudrais souligner en termes de
performance industrielle c'est que nous
avons nous faisons en sorte de préserver
au maximum les trafics de voyageurs
aussi parce que ça permet de préserver
nos péage est donc une recette
financière et c'est pour ça qu'un effort
considérable a été entrepris par
l'appareil de production et notamment
les les personnels de cette affaire fera
puisque sur ce réseau dits structurants
maintenant 40 % des travaux se font se
font la nuit
la troisième chose c'est que nous
travaillons ensemble nous travaillons
ensemble pour améliorer je dirai au
quotidien est un peu dans le détail la
performance industrielle notre appareil
de production
nous avons des engins de travaux qui
mérite d'être modernisé nous avons
aujourd'hui pas vous donner un simple
exemple de suite rapide sur le réseau
qui permettent je dirais en une nuit de
faire trois fois plus que les engins
classique voilà il ya une troisième
suite rapide qui va arriver début 2013
et je pourrais multiplier les exemples
où on pourrait voilà un peu dans le
détail améliorer les performances
industrielles
le troisième point que je voudrais faire
pour ne pas être long sur les sur les
partenaires publics privés puisque les
poser la question c'est un sujet
effectivement qui dépasse un petit peu
le champ de cette audition ce que je
voudrais au moins par rapport à ce qui
nous intéresse
s'il ya peut-être un mérite des ppp qui
mérite d'être considéré c'est que le ppp
oblige à mettre sur la table au départ
l'ensemble du coût d'une ligne nouvelle
se dire non seulement son compte
construction mais son coût de
maintenance et donc il ya un certain
gain de transparence a posé sur la table
entre le partenaire public est le
partenaire privé
le coût du réseau sur d'une ligne
nouvelle sur 25 ans sur 50 ans et
d'anticiper dans ce coût global
le coût de la maintenance le coût de
l'entretien ensuite on peut débattre des
conditions financières
mais il ya je dirai au moins cette
obligation poser de penser la ligne dans
son coût global un quatrième point je
voudrais mentionner pour terminer c'est
l'unification du chasseur
d'infrastructures très clairement je
crois que nous gagnerions beaucoup en
efficacité si effectivement les
différents métiers d'infrastructures
c'est-à-dire sncf infra rff et puis
direction de circulations ferroviaires
étaient regroupés dans une même entité
je devrais dire simplement deux choses
d'abord c'est que nous cherchons je
dirais par anticipation a préfiguré par
des plateaux comme industriels sur
différents projets a préfiguré voilà ce
que serait le fonctionnement je dirais
plus plus unifiée des fonctions des
fonctions essentielles de
l'infrastructure la deuxième chose que
je voudrais dire c'est si un jour les
fonctions essentielles doivent être
regroupés ce serait pour nous en termes
industriels et contractuels évidemment
un progrès en progrès potentiel ce prêt
potentiel de mon point de vue il se fait
quand même deux conditions d'abord
il faut que le système reste le
transparent vis-à-vis de toutes les
parties prenantes l'état les régions et
donc je crois qu'il faudra que ce futur
de l'infrastructure soit transparent sur
ses coûts l'état du réseau et que ceux
ci puissent continuer continuer à être
suivi je pense qu'on a besoin comme je
lis d'avoir une tutelle forte et une
participation des régions pour clarifier
ce qu'est la consistance du réseau les
trafics que l'on veut je crois enfin qu'
il est important de mentionner le rôle
du régulateur vous savez que dans le
paysage institutionnel français depuis
maintenant deux ans nous avons
l'autorité de régulation des activités
ferroviaires qui est en place et je
pense que si nous sommes unis si un jour
nous n'aurons plus d' excuse je dirais à
ne pas être performant et productif et
je pense que l'un des rôles du
régulateur à côté de la tutelle
c'est aussi voilà comme dans les airs
autres entreprises qui sont régulés et
les autres secteurs régulés de pousser
le gestionnaire d'infrastructure à plus
d'efficacité année après année si
monsieur qui n'est monsieur izard que je
vais je vais être assez rapide
adam est amené deux compléments à ce qui
vient d'être dit on tout d'abord
j'aimerais de lever un doute puisqu'il a
été mentionnée par le président tout à
l'heure c'est celui de la pertinence de
l'unification du gestionnaire
d'infrastructure pour le lever je dirais
que nous vivons un système qui est une
exception une exception en europe le
même une exception dans le monde entier
avec ce dispositif à deux acteurs l'un
qui est gestionnaire d'infrastructure
l'aude qui sont déléguées et la
complexité les multiples interfaces que
l'on vient d'évoquer un instant la
deuxième le deuxième terme de conviction
c'est que je constate que partout en
europe il ya des gestionnaires
d'infrastructures qui regroupe la
totalité des compétences qui viennent
d'être rappelés à l'instant et que ses
modèles fonctionnent marche que les
dispositifs de mise en en pression en
sollicitations de d'efficacité des
gestionnaires d'infrastructures sont là
pays par pays et que bien évidemment on
concevra comment le faire également chez
nous il a été mentionné
la notion de contrat de performance qui
a déjà existé pour un premier entre les
chefs d'état qui se travaille pour un
second pour moi c'est même plus que cela
ce qui mettra en pression de l'acteur en
question c'est véritablement la
gouvernance de l'entité qui auront été
créés et quand je regarde ce qui se
passe dans les autres pays d'europe mais
nous passons du temps à comprendre
comment ça fonctionne dans les autres
pays d'europe
on voit bien que c'est l'exigence de
performance de l'entité elle-même portée
par ses ce sont sa gouvernance autrement
dit par ses conseils d'administration
par son modèle et nous avons suggéré que
ce soit plutôt un modèle en conseil de
surveillance et directoire pour qui est
véritablement un lieu qui veillent fixer
des orientations et et qui surveille la
bonne gestion d'une équipe qui
véritablement sera responsable de la
bonne gestion industrielle technique
économique financière sociale de
l'ensemble regroupé quelqu'un a
mentionné le 10e adam que tout ceci
peut-il réellement aboutir alors que les
acteurs ont pris peut-être l'habitude de
se disputer
je voudrais témoigner que les travaux
que nous menons ensemble sur des sujets
précis qui ont été évoqués par alain
quinet à l'instant en donnant une
mission des acteurs à la fois de sncf
infra structures et des ff et des
objectifs et donc en leur demandant de
nous rendre compte deux trois six mois
près de leurs travaux nous permettent
vite de ne plus distinguer qui est quoi
est elle véritablement de l'envy donne
du souffle
autrement dit face qui compte ce sera le
projet ce sera la capacité d'emporter
les 50000 personnes vers un projet
nouveau qui aura de la saveur qui sera
motivant pour des équipes des équipes
nombreuses donc c'est une affaire de
management qui est sous la question que
vous avez soulevé mon dernier
commentaire qu'il le touche
l'équation financière et au cou lors des
assises du ferroviaire
nous avions été beaucoup questionné sur
l'avantagé économique de ce regroupement
du gestionnaire d'infrastructure et nous
avions tenté d'en donner un ordre de
grandeur
nous avions explicité que les gains
pourraient se situer à nos yeux entre
400 et 600 millions de dépenses
annuelles sur le fonctionnement de
l'infrastructure à l'horizon 2020
documenté cela et c'est bien sûr à votre
disposition sont des documents publics
qui ont été déposées à ce moment à la
fois par des effets de productivité mais
aussi de simplification de réduction
d'assiette d'interface de diminutions de
coûts de structure entre nos entités et
ça n'est qu'une partie du chemin où
quelqu'un citer 1 milliards 2,1
milliards 3 comme étant le déficit et
l'endettement complémentaire annuelle du
système ferroviaire donc ce que j'évoque
las on couvrira peut-être un tiers
jeunes et c'est déjà un pas significatif
c'est la contribution que je crois la
gestion d'infrastructures pourra
apporter à une meilleure équation du
système ferroviaire tout entier voilà
donc pour cette audition qui a eu lieu
mercredi dernier salle clémenceau au
sénat vous pouvez bien sûr toujours
retrouver la séance et les différentes
auditions sur notre site publicsenat.fr
très bonne journée sur les chaînes
parlementaires
non